[Música]
esses dias estava arrumando os cadernos
papéis e eu encontrei uma uma folha jogo
americano aqueles de bar e café sabe
nessa folha de uma frase que estava
escrito
eu pedia para o papai noel o fim das
guerras e ele me dava uma boneca
essa frase e esse papai noel que não
acabou com as guerras estava escrito
nesse papel esse que a gente tem bar e
café de restaurantes junto com algumas
outras frases tipo a gente sabe da
criança quando amadurece
imagina se a gente pudesse fazer tudo o
que a gente pode também tinha frases
como a vida é muito curta e uma onda
muito grande também tinha essa eu pisei
no pé de uma socialite esse dia eu
estava com uma amiga acho que era um bar
não era um café sentar nesses lugares
pegar esse papel e escrever
amy vasculhar é tentar entender qual é o
meu repertório
qual é o meu mapa de inspiração a onde
começam as minhas transformações e aí a
primeira pergunta que eu queria fazer
para vocês hoje a qual o repertório de
vocês
qual é o mapa de inspiração de vocês
vocês são únicos por definição que faz
de vocês únicos
segundo o meu mapa de inspiração tem a
ver com eventos têm a ver com tentasse
chef de cozinha teve com design tv com
fitinhas adesivas coloridas tv com velas
flores
essas coisas se conectam e elas fazem de
mim que eu sou
e vocês o que inspira vocês pra quem não
sabe que são fitinhas coloridas adesivas
são essas
o meu mapa de inspiração também tem a
ver com bicicleta
eu mudei para são paulo faz uns três
anos mais ou menos
e eu queria muito comprar uma bicicleta
e as pessoas começaram a falar não
compra é perigoso
não não compre espera ter mais ciclovia
e será mais pessoas andarem aí também
anda mas a frase não era seja mudança
que você quer de no mundo ou é espera
mudança acontecer e aí você também muda
eu ainda tenho medo de andar de
bicicleta em são paulo
todos os dias quando saiu de casa e pega
uma bicicleta eu tenho medo que a gente
faz com esse medo eu era criança uma vez
que o meu pai me colocou numa pista diz
que ele me levou lá pra cima e me deixou
a sozinha aí ele voltou e eu fiquei
muito confortável achei que ele ia me
levar de volta para a base ou pro hotel
o sofá pra ficar dormindo pra sempre
ele olhou pra mim e falou tá com medo do
eleitor vai com medo mesmo
foi isso que ele me disse toda vez que
eu saio de casa de bicicleta eu tenho
medo de andar de bicicleta assim como eu
tenho medo de várias outras coisas invés
de não fazer uma coisa porque eu tenho
medo
resolvi criar maneiras engraçadas
criativas e divertidas para fazer as
coisas mesmo assim eu chego doados
motoristas doe joinha eu aviso pra eles
que eu vou dobrar às vezes eu peço por
favor não me atropela hoje eu queria
voltar para casa
e tem funcionado
tem que começar em ser rápido e tem que
partir de vocês de você
uber da meo oberdan mel é uma sensação
oberdan mel em cadeirinha de bebê
transporta cachorro com carinho
busquei leva seu desapego transporta sua
bike entrega documentos com segurança
busca sua filha na balada e transporta
você bêbado
talvez ele também busca sua filha bêbada
na balada os documentos foram de
bicicleta eo seu desapego não sair
rubber da meo também leva você para doar
sangue
grátis rubber da meo tem a ver com
repertório da meo
as pessoas acham legal elas se conectam
por que é de verdade que é único porque
pessoal e é humano e são as conexões
humanas que fazem a gente mais humanas
tem que começar agora pode ser pequeno
mas em parte de vocês eu vou tentar
contar uma história agora eu nunca
contei público
na época eu me neguei a contar para
jornalistas e imprensa
e é muito simbólico tentar contar essa
história no dia de hoje mas eu vou
tentar
alguns anos atrás aconteceu uma tragédia
numa cidade do interior do rio grande do
sul chamada santa maria
vários e vários jovens que dançavam
alegres uma boate morreram num incêndio
eu estava lá estava andando de bicicleta
com o meu pai que me colocava em
descidas e subidas íngremes e eu chegava
ele o tempo todo ela de manhã cedo a
gente estava numa pousada que a gente já
viu a notícia e aquilo me doeu
taí uma lágrima e uma pessoa perguntou
mas tinha um amigo seu lá eu falei 'não
não tinha nenhum amigo meu mas sim
amigos de muitas pessoas lá tinha filhos
de pessoas filhas de pessoas namorados
genros noras não conhecer ninguém
conhecia todo mundo a gente saiu para
andar de bicicleta e aquela voz
continuar me chamando
como será que essas pessoas estão que
aconteceu porque elas precisam imagina
se fosse alguém que eu conheço
eu voltei pra casa eu comecei a entrar
na internet e eu descobri que foi
montado um ginásio para as famílias das
pessoas para os amigos das pessoas
aguardarem por notícias por liberações
de corpos ea internet se mobilizavam
para que a gente conseguisse ajudar
essas pessoas de alguma forma e foi aí
que descobri que eles precisavam de
papel higiênico
eles precisavam de muito mais que isso
mas naquele momento eles precisavam de
papel higiênico
eu olhei aquilo que falei eu vou sair de
casa eu vou comprar quanto o papel
higiênico conseguir com o meu dinheiro é
tão estúpido é tão pouco aquela ideia
parecia tão besta mari
você vai sair de casa para comprar papel
higiênico pessoas que perderam amigos
amigas e ao mesmo tempo falar eu vou eu
vou eu liguei para uma amiga minha a
gabi e gabi você quer comprar papel
higiênico também eu posso ir comprar por
nós duas
e aí foi quando a galp teve a idéia de
colocar uma vaquinha no ar
foi quando ela me disse mário eu vou
colocar o nosso ao nosso teto de
arrecadação em 2000 reais
a gente nunca vai conseguir dois mil
reais
quarenta e oito mil reais foi o
resultado da nossa vaquinha a minha vida
virou uma gincana
eu tive que aprender tudo sobre a lei de
doação no brasil eu tive que falar com
advogados
a gente montou uma central para entender
o que as pessoas precisavam lá e como a
gente poderia ajudar mas eu tinha só
saído de casa para comprar papel
higiênico era tão pequeno era tão pouco
várias pessoas começaram a nos ajudar
também a gente ia no supermercado e
comprava muitas e muitas coisas
esse é o recibo de uma das compras
ele já quase o dobro do meu tamanho
a gente não pode subestimar o poder dos
detalhes a força de começar algo mas tem
que partir de vocês
a transformação é a nossa energia única
e humana e movimento
vasco cunha que tem dentro de vocês vão
com medo atrevam-se começar algo pode
ser muito muito perigoso e pode ser
também muito transformador
já pensou se a gente pudesse fazer tudo
o que a gente realmente pode ou se o
papai noel conseguisse acabar com a
guerra
obrigada
[Aplausos]